welcome back it's a congressional stock
scandal for US senators now under fire
for selling off millions of dollars
worth of stocks in the days before the
corona virus crashed the American
economy Democrat Dianne Feinstein and
Republicans Richard Burr Kelly Lafleur
and James Inhofe all dumped assets
following a reportedly classified all
senators briefing at the end of January
now all four the senators are denying
any wrongdoing and senator burr is
calling for an ethics review of his own
actions
senator Lafleur was grilled this morning
by fox's Edie Henry on America's
newsroom you thought the government was
prepared yet shortly after that tweet
that I just noted you sold over a
million dollars in stocks in your own
personal portfolio before the market
went down were you trading on inside
information about what was coming well
I'm really glad you asked Edie because I
do want to set the record straight I've
seen some of those stories and it's
absolutely false and it could not be
true so if you actually look at the
personal transaction reports that were
filed it notices at the bottom that I'm
only informed of my transactions after
they occur several weeks so I mean it's
hard to make sense of all of this so let
me just start by asking you Jessie is
this serious in the Loffler case it's
also an issue that not only did she sell
stuff but then she bought stuff and one
of the items she bought was to help
people who have to work at home software
what do you think it looks really bad
all four of them have different levels
of sketchiness I'll start with the least
sketchy Inhofe says he was never even at
the briefing on the virus and said he's
been moving money from stocks to mutual
funds for the last two years he sold the
least amount of stock Feinstein's says
you know what it was a blind trust it
was my husband's doing I wasn't even at
the briefing on the virus either and it
was just one company but it was six
million dollars in a biotech company we
don't really know much else about that
now Loffler her husband's the chairman
of the New York Stock Exchange
she sold these stocks on the day of the
briefing right after it happened and
like you said not only she sell
stocke she bought a stock which benefits
from a software that helps teleworking
people that work from home it doesn't
look very good perfectly-timed also
perfectly timed Richard Burr liquidated
almost his entire portfolio and he has
all the Intel because he's the top Intel
guy in the Senate and he was telling
people privately that this pandemic was
going to be as bad as the 1918 Spanish
flu pandemic also perfectly timed right
before the market dropped and he said oh
well I traded it because I saw some news
on CNBC I think everybody needs to be
investigated and treated fairly but a
really bad look Emily senator burr says
simply you know what it wasn't my
actions even if you were to try to put
him together the fact is he says he had
no special intelligence although he's
the chairman the Intelligence Committee
he says everything that he did was based
on public reports what do you think
right he said I only listen to CNBC
covering the Asia markets look in my
opinion to kind of go off of Jesse's
like ranking of the outlaws the top two
are the worst and senator Byrd's is the
worst by far it's worse than Lafleur and
here's why because his reported net
worth two years ago was 1.7 million and
as you just said he sold off between
600,000 and 1.7 million so nearly all of
his reported net worth and of course the
disparity between his public and his
private comments and his vote in 2012
against a rule in Congress banning
insider training it obviously raises a
lot of questions and LeFleur by the way
her reported net worth is 500 million
and the most she reportedly sold off was
3.1 million so that's less than 1% she
has the same defense that Feinstein does
which is I didn't know about it I
learned about it weeks after you know
swaiiow Feinstein says it's in a blind
trust other people do it for me but
we'll see what happens
well Greg what do you think I mean
you're normally you're skeptical I know
as public officials sometimes angry you
suppose what are you thinking about this
I am more upset I guess at all of them
for not knowing more about the issue in
general yet
no I agree with everything that Jessie
and Emily said about the levels of guilt
but I'm kind of ticked up what was what
date was that meeting it was an end of
January into February January 24 okay so
that was we did we talked on the five
right when the president was shutting
down the travel yeah exactly so they
could they could argue that they watched
the five and heard us arguing about it
that's what I would do if I was our
lawyer but instead they said they watch
CNBC two things I'm more upset that
these people weren't on the ball two or
three weeks earlier and could have and
could have acted more for the heat for
that for the American people than their
stop for portfolio but I'm also just
ticked off in general at the stock
market in the in the in the instability
and frantic emotional response they are
every day I mean today it's swung from
eight hundred up to a nine hundred down
and it's like I feel like I'm around a
drunk you know driving down the middle
of the road and it's like can we drug
the stock market can we drug them for a
month put them to sleep and wake them up
and this is over it's a roller coaster
you know you know you know what struck
me was this report jesse touched on it
that burr was in a private luncheon at
the Capitol Hill Club in DC and he says
to his guests this is going to be like
the 1918 pandemic so how can he now say
that he do didn't know what was gonna
come in addition he wrote an op-ed piece
of basically saying the u.s. is prepared
okay so the interesting thing is this is
why people get mad about this um up
until 2012 insider trading by people
that are members of Congress was not
even illegal okay so and there was funny
business going on and so there was this
law so the stock Act comes into place
they have to report and this is the
thing this is the thing I mean think of
that I can't remember his name that
congressman from upstate New York who
makes the sends the text message from
the White House on the South Lawn where
they're having a congressional picnic
telling his family hey you might want to
sell this look they get caught
and maybe I think here's what I would do
if I were ever gonna be a member of
Congress I would want to not know
exactly we want to put it in a blind
trust so that you just not even have the
possibility what do you have a
perception that like this I mean that's
if this ends any careers it's a terrible
terrible legacy mm-hmm well now that
you've said it I don't know what I'm
going to do with my vote for Perino
button but you know you'll never have to
wear it all right